i think this is hilarious um did you
know that someone
honored you with a sandwich did you know
that there's a sandwich named after you
and it's
awesome what yes and i'm so jealous i
want a sandwich
so sammich restaurant in ashland oregon
is serving
the queen leba
the queen leba come on
my assistant jonathan is handing me
a queen labifa yes okay y'all it comes i
love you so much justin
it comes with steak jalapeno cream
cheese spread and red onion on sourdough
rice so
i'm just saying we should taste it it's
a queen of beefa
because it's just never that's never
gonna not be funny this is the largest
sandwich in the entire world
ava oh damn that's good
yeah is it good yes it's so good
your queen label sandwich is so good
[Laughter]
look i'm about to spray my queen of
beefs
covered friendly it is so good
you've got to try it it's so good thank
you so much sandwich restaurant in
ashland oregon that was amazing
all right so be sure y'all see you like
it don't you it's so good get that
little bit yep
you're so classy i totally talked with
my mouth open i got to take lessons on
class from the queen
it's all about this right here that's me
too yes
it's so good yeah i mean
i know i like some spice i like some
[Music]
spice